[Musique]
les gens tirent les conclusions en me
retirant de la vie politique je crois
que c'est à moi de détails
salut à tous en politique le débat n'est
pas toujours courtois et il arrive que
l'on manie l'injure invectives ou
l'insultent certaines n'ont pas besoin
d'être expliquée mais d'autres injures
sont spécifiques au monde politique
et aujourd'hui on va parler de l'une
d'entre elles l'islamo gauchisme en
raison du contexte actuel l'insulteur
revient à la mode et elle demande
quelques explications
d'ailleurs il s'agit même d'une double
insulte de schiste étant un terme
inventé par lénine pour désigner tous
ceux qui sont plus radicaux pluie et y
accoler un termes religieux est d'autant
plus insultants qui longtemps la gauche
socialiste a été hâtée et anti
religieuse du coup l'islamo gauchisme
c'est à la fois une radicalité inutile
et une dégénérescence intellectuelle
autant dire que c'est un terme qui fait
pas plaisir mais de fait c'est insultant
recouvre une réalité une pratique
politique lié à l'émergence d'une
nouvelle religion dans l'espace public
en europe
et cette réalité je vous propose
d'essayer de la cerner si le mot
islamo-gauchiste aidé en france je vous
propose d'abord faire un détour par
l'angleterre car c'est dans ce pays que
des militants d'extrême gauche ont
théorisé puis mis en pratique les
rapprochements avec l'islam politique
ils peuvent donc nous servir d'étalon
pour voir ensuite ce qui se fait en
france
les premiers et les seuls à ma
connaissance avoir théorisé l'action
commune entre l'extrême gauche l'islam
politique
ce sont les anglais du socialiste worker
partie tout petit parti trotskiste qui
est l'équivalent du npa en france en
chris ortman l'un des leaders du parti
écrit un texte intitulé le prophète et
le prolétariat dans lequel il propose à
son parti une nouvelle orientation
vis-à-vis de l'islamisme alors
l'islamisme pour le définir très vite
c'est une idéologie né dans les années
30 en egypte alors sous domination
anglaise au sein d'une confrérie appelé
les frères musulmans les islamistes
considèrent que l'islam n'est pas une
religion que l'on peut vivre en
individuel dans n'importe quelle société
puisque nombre de prescriptions divines
amis ne concerne pas l'individu mais les
rapports sociaux
le croyant pour vraiment vivre selon la
volonté de dieu venant vivre dans une
société musulmane
c'est à dire régie par la charia de plus
il considère souvent que les seuls vrais
musulmans ceux des premiers siècles
voire même uniquement la première
génération qui a côtoyé le prophète dont
il faudrait alors reproduire le mode de
vie c'est donc une forme de réaction de
refus radical des valeurs occidentales
alors dominante politiquement et
culturellement dans les pays musulmans
par exemple il ya un refus de la mixité
est souvent de la démocratie qui sont
vus comme des valeurs occidentales
également une faut noter qu islamiste ne
veut pas forcément dire pianiste mais il
s'agit quand même de l'équivalent des
cathos intégristes en europe
il s'agit clairement d'une mouvance
d'extrême droite pour en revenir à arman
aussi ce qu'il dit dans son texte le
prophète est le prolétariat jusqu aux
années 90
il ya deux façons d'aborder l'islamisme
à gauche il ya d'abord ceux qui y voient
une lutte anti occidentales cela au nom
de la lutte contre le capitalisme et
l'impérialisme occidental ont soutenu
l'islamisme par exemple en france dans
les années 70 des intellectuels de
gauche et pas des moindres comme sartre
foucault ont soutenu la révolution
iranienne qui a renversé le chah alors
allié des états unis
ils ont créé des comités de soutien et
sont notamment allés rendre visite
arménie lors de son exil dans notre vie
et ça me poser lors de problème à
personne que celui-ci ne parle pas aux
femmes ce sont un peu des prêts des
proto d archéo islamo gauchiste
face à ces ancêtres des islamo gauchiste
il y avait ceux qui voyaient dans
l'islamisme l'équivalent du fascisme une
idéologie rétrograde totalitaire et bien
souvent violentes notamment envers les
opposants de gauche chris arman vwp
lille à dire c'est plus compliqué que ça
il va analyser l'islamisme en termes
marxistes
c'est à dire en termes de classes
sociales et de domination économique et
il va en conclure que l'islamisme régner
dans les classes bourgeoises et qui
séduit aussi les classes défavorisées
car il porte un discours social
la réponse sociale de l'islamisme est
simple une société musulmane
suivant les règles nahla est une société
juste via son discours marxiste il va
considérer qu'il ya quand même une
contradiction dans l'islamisme la
société musulmane parfaite proposé par
les leaders ne peut être socialement
juste
car c'est une société de classe elle va
donc décevoir les pauvres et les gens de
bonne volonté qui ont adhéré à cette
idéologie en quête de justice sociale il
faut donc travailler avec les islamistes
quand on peut pour tenter de convaincre
la base que si elle veut l'égalité qu'il
faut une société communiste et non
islamiques
toujours est il que cette stratégie va
être mis en place après le 11 septembre
2001 les guerres en afghanistan et en
irak consécutive aux attentats
vous permettre aux swp de passer de la
théorie à la pratique reste wp va être à
l'initiative de la création d'un
collectif anti guerre stop the war
regroupant organisations de gauche et
musulmane dont certaines islamistes
comme la mab la muslim association of
britain affiliés aux frères musulmans
puis en 2004
à partir de ce collectif va se créer
respecte un cartel électoral
une sorte une front de gauche mais un
peu spécial car en plus des trotskistes
et de quelques socialistes
on trouve aussi entre autres des
islamistes du mahb respecte va notamment
réussir à faire élire des conseillers
municipaux en s'appuyant notamment sur
des imams mais surtout il va réussir à
faire élire un député george galloway à
socialiste en rupture avec le parti
travailliste
galloway s'est appuyé explicitement sur
le communautarisme religieux pour tenter
de se faire élire et il se présente dans
plusieurs circonscriptions populaires à
forte population musulmane
cette stratégie finira par payer et il
sera finalement élu député en 2005 puis
en 2012 dans deux circonscriptions
différentes stop the war et respecte
pour parler aux milieux musulmans en
devoir faire quelques compromis avec les
idées de gauche
par exemple ils vont tenir des meetings
dans les centres islamiques ou les
publics sont séparés selon le sexe forme
d'un côté les femmes de l'autre ans
n'est pas homme devant et fédérer
le tout avec une relative hypocrisie
puisque lors d'un meeting un militant
proche du swp expliquera que les femmes
sont derrière car les sièges qui sont
plus confortables
ces compromis ne seront pas sans
conséquence et en 2007 respecte
scissionne laisse wpd non seulement la
chasse aux trotskistes qui a court quand
les antilles swp eux accusent les
trotskistes de trop tenir le parti est
en fait quand on lit les critiques du
swp sur le fonctionnement de respecte on
voit que les trotskistes reproche à la
coalition de devenir trop puisque la
mort gauchistes et critique notamment la
stratégie de galloway de s'allier avec
les leaders religieux réactionnaire pour
se faire élire il faut dire que galloway
dérive de l'islamo gauchisme stratégie
militante au communautarisme stratégie
électorale et gestionnaires consistant à
ne plus considérer les citoyens comme
des individus mais comme des moutons
gérés par des leaders communautaires
qu'ils soient ethniques ou religieux
également laisse wp recrute certains
compromis comme le non soutien à la gay
pride de londres il est vrai qu'elle
lutte des minorités sexuelles ne sont
pas très populaires chez les populations
musulmanes après cette dérive
communautariste c'est aussi une
conséquence de la société
multiculturelle anglaise puisque le
parti travailliste l'équivalent anglais
du parti socialiste a lui aussi été
pointée pour tolérer des compromis avec
un islam parfois réactionnaire c'est le
cas notamment de jeremy courbine qui a
d'ailleurs été membre de respecte et qui
a lui même tenu des meetings séparer les
thèses du wpc les anglais débat au sein
du mouvement trotskyste internationale
on peut percer en angleterre en france
seuls deux groupuscules de quelques
dizaines de personnes nous fait
référence socialisme international et
socialisme par-en-bas souvent abrégé ans
peine oui ce nom fait beaucoup rire
ces deux groupuscules ont ensuite au
cours des années 2000 intégrer la lcr
qui est l'ancêtre du npa
en france le rapport à l'islam s'est
fait de façon plus vague et en
angleterre
il n'y a pas eu de collaboration avec
des groupes islamistes même si parfois
la cause palestinienne a permis des
cohabitations dans notre pays les
rapprochements avec l'islam politique et
se font vraiment à partir des années
2000 sur la question du voile à l'école
pour faire simple les premiers quarts de
voile à l'école apparaissent en 1989 les
jeunes filles sont exclus et globalement
après un emballement médiatique initiale
le sujet fini par se tasser et au cours
des années 90
les deux cas sont signalés et tous sont
traités par l'exclusion des jeunes
filles voilées exclusion s'appuyant sur
une circulaire de l'éducation nationale
contre les signes religieux
ostentatoires
le sujet revient sur le devant de la
scène politique en 2003 ans jacques
chirac décide de créer une commission
appelée commission stasi dénonçons
dans chargé de porter une réflexion sur
les thèmes de la laïcité en france
incluant la question du voile à l'école
la commission après de nombreuses
auditions propose plusieurs mesures
comme par exemple la création de deux
nouveaux jours fériés et l'instauration
de la nuque de substitution dans les
cantines la loi qui en résultera
rejettera la religion hors de l'école
l'interdiction du voile étant
définitivement acté mais le débat
ressurgit vite avec la question des
mères accompagnatrices qui porte le
voile
globalement avant le quinquennat
hollande ces mamans sont interdites de
sortie scolaire
en réponse au cours des années 2000 2010
et collectif musulman pour le voile à
l'école et sur le thème des mères
voilées vont se créer on peut citer les
collectif une école pour tout ou mamans
toutes égales ou encore le collectif
féministe pour l'égalité au début des
années 2000 l'extrême gauche 33
positions différentes sur la question de
la visibilité l'islam à l'école il ya
d'abord la position laïcarde qui est la
position typiquement de lutte ouvrière
qui rejette la religion il ya ensuite la
position ni voile ni loi position
personnellement j'appelle un gauchiste
puisque irréaliste dans les fêtes et qui
est surtout le fait de groupuscules
ayant enfin la position pro voile qui
elle elle la position typiquement de la
lcr il faut dire qu'à partir du début
des années 2010 islam va être perçu
comme une religion victime de racisme
il faut donc défendre la position pro
vol va alors devenir évidente quand les
deux autres options font devenir un
garde la position de lutte ouvrière
lagarde va même devenir réactionnaire
aux yeux d'une grande partie d'extrême
gauche
et puis progressivement une partie
l'extrême gauche a commencé à travailler
avec ces collectifs musulmans mais aussi
avec des organisations religieuses comme
présence et spiritualité musulmane où le
collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france et c'est ainsi que l'on va voir
apparaître des aberrations idéologique
comme la collaboration avec des
islamistes
car depuis le début je vous parle de
collectif musulman mais il faut regarder
de plus près qui composent ces
collectifs et ce qu'ils sont réellement
ainsi une militante en particulier
ismahane chouder multiplie les
casquettes co présidente du collectif
féministe pour l'égalité
membre du collectif une école pour tout
membre fondatrice du collectif mamans
toutes égales
il se trouve qu'ils se vendent schoder
et membre de participation et
spiritualité musulmane
l'antenne française un mouvement
islamiste marocain justice et
bienveillance au niveau islamistes
participation et spiritualité musulmane
est relativement soft sur l'échelle
d'intégrisme religieux on peut
considérer qu'ils sont à nouveau de
christine boutin
d'ailleurs tout comme christine boutin
psm est opposée au mariage gay quant au
collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france
il s'agit d'une structure réputé proche
des frères musulmans créée par un ancien
prédicateur intégristes samy debah les
dirigeants actuels du collectif lui
marwan muhammad est coutumier des
conférences en présence d'intégristes le
ccf à une définition très large d islam
allant des musulmans normaux modérée au
plus intégristes ainsi ils considèrent
comme islamophobe l'expulsion des neuf
intégristes ou la fermeture de mosquée
radicale clairement de s'essayer défend
systématiquement les pratiques les plus
intégristes et les interprétations les
plus radicales sous couvert de lutte
contre l'islamophobie
on peut considérer que c'est une
structure qui est un objectif politique
inavoués car défendre des intégristes
c'est légitimer et favoriser la
diffusion de leur discours bref au
milieu des années 2010 une grande parti
d'extrême-gauche travaille
ponctuellement une des collectifs
musulmans voir avec des islamistes mais
les choses vont vraiment s'accélérer à
partir de janvier 2015 et des attentats
contre charlie hebdo
ces attentats sont à la fois révélateur
est un accélérateur c'était à mon avis à
partir de ce moment là on peut
réellement parler d'islam un gauchisme à
la française après ces attentats on a vu
des réactions adhérentes à l'extrême
gauche une semaine après les tueries il
ya eu une manifestation au cours de
laquelle se sont mêlés gauchisme islam
politique et au cours de laquelle tout
était mélangé dénonciation
l'islamophobie cause palestinienne
racisme c'est une manifestation où on
entendu d allahou akbar et où on avait
l'impression que la première victime des
attentats c'était l'islam également en
mars 2015 s'est tenue une conférence
contre l'islamophobie ou des islamistes
se sont retrouvés aux côtés des
gauchistes et puis on offre aussi de
nombreux militants ont accusé charlie
hebdo de racisme anti musulman
rejoignant en cela les islamistes qui ne
supportait pas la liberté de ton du
journal c'est l'une des raisons peut
avoir dans public qui ont fait qu'on a
plus entendu l'extrême gauche se
solidariser avec les victimes
après les attentats alors depuis le
début je reste vague je parle d'extrême
gauche en général mais de keynes
organisation par le ton juste et bien
tout d'abord d'une et à qui est le fer
de lance cette dérive
tout simplement parce que ses militants
sont les plus nombreux la seule autre
organisation d'importance que l'on peut
classer parmi les islamo gauchistes
c'est ensemble
partis du front de gauche cette
structure est plus connue est
généralement connais un peu plus une de
ses porte parole clémentine atteint pour
le coup valls qui la traitaient 10 km
aux gauchistes qui était dans le vrai
également des structures rattachées à
des syndicats comme solidaire où la cgt
est occasionnellement être associés à
des événements islamo-gauchiste normal
une partie de leurs adhérents sont aussi
des militants d'extrême gauche
en fait globalement et cela l'extrême
gauche c'est à dire plus à gauche que le
pcf et la france est soumise à ne pas
tomber à un degré ou à un autre dans
cette dérive ces luttes ouvrières
tout simplement parce que c'est une
organisation complètement sclérosé
imperméable à toute nouvelle idée voilà
vous savez maintenant identifiée
l'islamo gauchisme et qui précisément
traiter d'islamophobe schiste mais il
faut aussi s'interroger car cette
insulte si elle dénonce une aberration
de gauche est aussi un symptôme ou c'est
le symptôme d'une faillite et d'une
transformation intellectuelle d'une
faillite d'abord car incapable de parler
au prolétariat dont elle remplit ses
discours une partie de l'extrême gauche
sans l'avouer a remplacé la figure de
l'ouvrier dans son logiciel idéologique
par celle de l'immigré sur tous les
musulmans l'islam étant vus depuis la
décolonisation comme la religion des
pauvres progressivement chez beaucoup un
critique du capitalisme système
économique s'est doublée voire a été
remplacé par la critique de l'occident
ensemble culturel qui s'est longtemps
cru universel alors que ces valeurs sont
relatives mais au nom de cette critique
de l'universalisme de cet ethnocentrisme
et occidentale islam au gauchisme en
vient à s'allier avec l'extrême droite
musulmane qui a tout jeté alors que
c'est dans cet occident certes
imparfaite que les femmes ou les homos
par exemple se sont émancipés ou que
l'on a pu prendre du recul par rapport à
une religion c'est ce qui fait de cette
extrême gauche l'idiot utile des
islamistes qui eux pour imposer une
société conforme alors nul besoin de
détruire les valeurs de cet occident
libéral ensuite cet islam au gauchisme
en france tout du moins c'est le signe
d'une transformation intellectuelle et
de l'adoption de nouvelles théories par
la gauche si vous suivez l'actualité
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler il
s'agit du féminisme sanglant des idées
des colonials post coloniale ou encore
d'un nouvel anti racisme que certains
dénoncent comme un racisme car oui ceux
qui succombent aux sirènes de l'islamo
gauchisme sont aussi ceux qui encensent
ces nouvelles théories radical dont l'
alliance ponctuelle avec les islamistes
n'est qu'une des facettes
en fait cette vidéo était un peu une
introduction à ses sujets et j'aborderai
ces théories problématique qui commence
à imprégner une partie de la gauche et
de la société dans de futurs vidéo
mais ça ce sera dans d'autres vidéos
celle ci est maintenant terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous aura appris des
choses vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine vidéo
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine
[Musique]